You are listening to radio lab radio lab
fromW , N y.
S. E. N. N. P. R.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab podcast.
And today on the podcast, something a little different.
A little while ago we happened to find ourselves on the stage of symphony space,
which is a theater in Manhattan in New York City.
And we were doing a show with selected shorts,
which is a radio show that's produced out of our home station,
w NYC hurdled across the country.
And they had asked us very generously to curate an evening of stories.
And so we chose a bunch of stories with the staff.
Got Some really unbelievably wonderful actors, like a who,
who is their main curtain with clear curtain Metta Story. Um,
Kara Cedric was there. Yeah. And, and leave Shriver read his story,
which you're going to hear. So we just want to play you that story,
which made up the second half of the show, uh, for this podcast.
And here's how that one began.
Hello.
Okay, we are back for part two. Um,
this next story could use a little bit of setup. We think, uh,
I don't know how many of you know this, but uh,
there is a theory but 25 years old now that explains how the Earth got a moon
and a, it goes like [inaudible].
Yes. So about four and a half billion years ago,
the earth was no fresh new planet was going around the sun and the solar system
was having a sort of a fire east sort of chaotic period and into the mix.
A very large planetoid about the size of Mars kind of went rogue and began
bumping around and there was a hit on collision between the earth and this
planet and the two one [inaudible] and the,
the incoming one melted much of the earth.
The earth became sort of vaporous and everything on the earth just went to gas
and it sort of flew up and then the earth just became sort of an unsolid for
awhile. When it cooled,
the earth fell back into place and there was this extra thing very,
very close by that we call [inaudible]
the moon. But ever since that, that moment, these two celestial orbs,
the earth and the moon have been very gradually, very,
very slowly drifting away from each other at a rate of,
and this is interesting, one nanometer per second, which is not a lot.
It's about a, just for practical,
practical sort of analogy that's about the speed that your fingernails grow. Uh,
but imagine your fingernails growing for four and a half billion years and
you've got a pretty long fingernail.
Yes. And are there are further away me? Yes.
So this is a story from Italo Calvino I'm just doing the FM radio.
I don't know how he really is. He's a Cuban born writer. He moved to Italy,
grew up there. They fought the Nazis for the end of World War II.
Wrote a book about that. Then what are many other books? And among them,
he created a series of stories called cosmic comics. Um,
they'll mostly have the same Matt narrator,
mysterious character called yes. What's he going?
Keep, keep, keep a quick,
you're having a whole debate and backstage about how to say this.
How do you spell it? You spell it.
[inaudible] F W F Q. Kief. Yeah. Cliff.
Cute paperwork for hell. You have to wait for it. [inaudible] the hill. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. The guy sort of that. So this uh, this fellow, he's very ancient.
He tells stories. Yeah.
Uh, it, the story is concluded the origin of the universe,
the beginning of time. So, uh,
and I should say it, it will be read for you today by an incredible actor,
director, producer, screenwriter,
and a man who flew for the last decade.
Would you say has been a Roberts unrequited boy crush?
Yeah, one sided, Bro. Man, it's not, it's not like sexual anything.
It's just like, but it is, it is a thing
because I
know
he just pops out.
We have come down under the stage and he hands me this little piece of paper
sort of pretending like he's handing Robert his phone number. But yeah,
definitely not. There's no way.
I was, I was watching it
play once, this is many years ago called don't look back.
And there was an actor in it named Jane Alexander, just amazing actress.
And she walked onto the stage in this play and she just dropped some luggage on
the stage and looked around and sh,
and in that moment she hadn't said anything yet. There was like a,
there was a history there. Uh, uh,
there was so much information before there was any sound.
I never saw that again until a few years ago in a view from the bridge.
VM Schreiber was, um, a longshoreman. He was just sitting.
The play begins and there's a guy sitting in chair reading a newspaper.
I think he turned a page. And so I'm sitting there and I'm seeing,
uh, an entire universe of a person.
And I don't know how he did it.
You may know his work from Glen Gary, Glen Ross, the loudest of the Mamet plays,
and he's on TV and stuff. I simply think he's, this is the Cressey Pie.
I think he's like the best living actor.
No, no pressure or anything.
Yeah. And he has to say per foot book. Uh,
it is a tall order.
Here he is to read a Italo Calvino's the distance of the moon. Liev Schreiber
[inaudible]
the distance of the moon by Italo Calvino at one time.
According to Sir George H Darwin, the moon was very close to the earth.
Then the tides gradually pushed her far away.
The tides that the moon herself causes in the earth's waters where the earth
slowly loses energy. How well,
I know old food
crime.
The rest of you can remember, but I can, we had her on top of us all the time.
That enormous moon when she was full, Nikes is brightest day,
but with a butter colored light. It looked as if she were going to crush us.
When she was new,
she rolled around the sky like a black umbrella blown by the wind and when she
was waxing, she came forward with her horn so low.
She seemed about to stick into the peak of a promintory and get caught there.
But the whole business of the moon's phases worked in a different way then
because the distances from the sun were different than the orbits and the angle
of the something or rather, I forget what.
As for eclipses with Earth and moon stuck together the way they were,
why we had eclipses every minute.
Naturally those two big monsters managed to put each other in the shade
constantly. First one, then the other orbit, oh elliptical.
Of course for a while it would huddle against us and then it would take flight.
For Awhile. The tides, when the moons swung closer, rose so high,
nobody could hold them back. There were nights when the moon was full and very,
very low and the tide was so high that the moon mist a dunking in the sea by a
hair's breath. No, let's say a few yards. Anyway,
climb up on the moon. Of course we did.
All you had to do was roll out in a boat when you're underneath,
prop a ladder against her and scramble up
the spot where the moon was lowest as she went by was off the sink cliffs.
We used to go out with those little rowboats they had in those days round and
flat made of Cork. They held quite a few of us. Me, Captain [inaudible],
the hid his wife, my deaf cousin, and sometimes it'll XL licks.
She was 12 or so at the time. On those nights,
the water was very calm, so silvery.
It looked like mercury on the fish in it. Violet colored,
unable to resist the moon's attraction, rose to the surface,
all of them and so did the octopuses and the saffron Medusas.
It was always a flight of tiny creatures, little crabs,
squid and even some weeds light and fill me in coral plants that broke from the
sea and ended up on the moon hanging down from the lime white ceiling or else
they stayed in midair, a phosphorescent swarm.
We had to drive off waving banana leaves at them.
This is how we did the job in the boat. We had a ladder.
One of us held it,
another climb to the top and a third at the oars road until we were right under
the moon. That's why there had to be so many of us.
I only mentioned the main ones,
the man at the top of the ladder as the boat approach,
the moon would become scared and starts shouting, stop, stop.
I'm going to Bang my head.
That was the impression you had seeing her on top of you or mentioned or rough
with sharps spikes and jagged saw tooth edges. It may be different now,
but then the moon or rather the, the,
the bottom or the underbelly of the moon,
the part that pass closest to the earth and almost scraped.
It was covered with a crust of sharp scales.
It had come to resemble the belly of a fish and the smell too, as I recall,
if not downright fishy,
was faintly similar like a smoked salmon.
In reality, from the top of the ladder, standing erect on the last rung,
you could just touch the moon if you're held your arms up.
We had taken the measurements carefully.
We didn't yet suspect that she was moving away from us.
The only thing you had to be very careful about was where you put your hands.
I always chose a scale and that seemed fast.
We climbed up in groups of five or six at a time.
Then I would cling first with one hand,
then with both and immediately I would feel ladder and boat drifting away from
below me and the motion of the moon would tear me from the earth attraction.
Yes, the moon was so strong that she pulled you up.
You realize this, the moment you passed from one to the other,
you had to swing up abruptly with a kind of somersault, grabbing the scales,
throwing your legs over your head until your feet were on the moon's surface
scene from the earth.
You looked as if you were hanging there with your head down,
but for you it was the normal position and then the only odd thing was that when
you raise your eyes,
you saw the sea above you listening with the boat and the others upside down,
hanging like a bunch of grapes from the vine. My cousin,
the death one showed a special talent for making those leaps,
his clumsy hands. As soon as they touched the lunar surface,
he was always the first to jump from the ladder.
Suddenly became deft and sensitive.
They found immediately the spot where he could hoist himself up. In fact,
just the pressure of his palm seemed enough to make him stick to the satellites
crust. Once I even thought I saw the moon come toward him.
As he held out his hands,
he was just as dextrous and coming back down to earth and operations still more
difficult for us. It consisted in jumping as high as we could.
Our arms upraised scene from the moon. That is because seen from the earth.
It looked more like a dive or like swimming downwards,
arms at our sides like jumping up from the earth. In other words,
only now we were without the ladder because there was nothing to prop it against
on the moon, but instead of jumping with his arms out,
my cousin bent toward the Moon's surface,
his head down as if for a summer sold then made a leap pushing with his hands
from the boat.
We watched him erect in the air as if he were supporting the moon's enormous
bowl and we're tossing it, striking it with his palms.
Then when his legs came within reach,
we managed to grab his ankles and pull them down on board.
Now you will ask me what in the world we went up on the moon for.
I'll explain it to you. We went to collect milk
with a big spoon and a bucket. Moon milk was very thick,
like a kind of cream cheese.
It formed in the crevices between one scale in the next through the fermentation
of various bodies and substances of terrestrial origin,
which had flown up from the prairies and forests and lakes.
As the moon sailed over them.
It was composed chiefly a vegetable juices,
tadpoles by human lentils, honey starts crystals, sturgeon,
eggs, molds, Pollins, gelatinous matter worms, resins, pepper,
mineral salts, combustion residue.
You had only to dip the spoon under the scales that covered the moon scabby
terrain and you brought it out, filled with that precious muck,
not in the pure state. Obviously there was a lot of refuse in the,
in the fermentation which took place as the moon passed over the expanses of hot
air above the deserts, not all the bodies melted.
Some remains stuck in it. Fingernails and cartilage bolts,
seahorses, nuts and peduncles, shards of Crockery fish hooks at times,
even a comb.
So this paste after it was collected had to be refined, filtered,
but that wasn't the difficulty.
The hard part was transporting it down to the earth. This is how we did it.
We hurled each spoonful into the air with both hands using the spoon as a
catapult. The cheese flew and if we had thrown it hard enough,
it stuck to the ceiling, I mean the surface of the sea.
Once there it floated and it was easy enough to pull it into the boat.
And this operation to my deaf cousin displayed a special gift.
He had a strength and a good aim with a single sharp throw.
He could send the cheese straight into a bucket.
We held up to him from the boat. As for me.
I occasionally misfired the contents of the spoon would often fail to overcome
the Moon's attraction and would fall back into my eyes.
I still haven't told you everything about the things.
My cousin was good at that job of extracting lunar milk from the moons scales
was child's play to him instead of the spoon.
At times he had only to thrust his bare hand under the scales or even one
finger. He didn't proceed in any orderly way, but went to isolated places.
Jumping from one to the other as if you were playing tricks on the moon,
surprising her or perhaps tickling her and reverie, put his hand,
the milk spurted out as if from a nanny, goats tits.
So the rest of us had only to follow him and collect with our spoons.
The substance that he was pressing out first here, then there,
but always as if by chance. Since the death ones,
movements seem to have no clear practical sense. There were places,
for example, that he touched merely for the fun of touching them.
Gaps between two scales,
naked and tender folds of lunar flesh. At times.
My cousin pressed Scott only his fingers about in a carefully gaged leap his big
toe,
he climbed onto the moon barefoot and this seemed to be the height of amusement
forum.
If we could judge by the chirping sounds that came from his throat as he went on
leaping.
The soil of the moon was not uniformly scaly,
but revealed irregular bare patches of Pale, slippery clay.
These soft areas inspired the deaf one to turn somersaults or to fly almost like
a bird, as if he wanted to impress his whole body into the moon's pulp.
As he ventured farther on his way, we lost sight of him.
At one point on the moon.
There were vast areas we had never had any reason or curiosity to explore,
and that was where my cousin vanished.
I suspected all those somersaults and nudges he indulged in before our eyes.
We're only a preparation,
a prelude to something secret meant to take place in the hidden zone.
We fell into a special mood on those nights, off the zinc cliffs gay,
but with a touch of suspense, as if inside our skulls instead of the brain,
we felt a fish floating attracted by the moon,
and so we navigated playing and singing. The captain's wife played the harp.
She had very long arms silvery his eels on those nights and armpits as dark and
mysterious as sea urchins. And the sound of the harp was sweet and piercing,
so sweet and piercing.
It was almost unbearable and we were forced to let out long cries,
not so much to accompany the music as to protect our hearing from it.
Transparent Medusas rose to the sea's surface throb there a moment,
then flew off, swaying toward the moon. Little Exelixis sucks,
amuse herself by catching them in midair, though it wasn't easy.
Once as she stretched her little arms out to catch run,
she jumped up sightly and was also set free. Then finished.
She was,
she was an ounce or two short of the weight necessary for the earth gravity to
overcome the moon's attraction and bring her back.
So she flew up among the Medusa's, suspended over the sea. She took fright,
cried then laughed, and started playing,
catching shellfish and minnows as they flew,
sticking some into her mouth and chewing them.
We rode hard to keep up with the child.
The moon ran off in her lips dragging that swarm of marine phone or through the
sky,
and a train of long entwined seaweeds and excellent sticks hanging there in the
midst. Her two wispy braids seem to be flying on their own,
outstretched toward the moon.
But all the while she kept wriggling and kicking at the air as if she wanted to
fight that influence and her socks.
She had lost her shoes and the flight slipped off her feet and suede attracted
by the earth force on the ladder. We tried to grab them.
The idea of eating little animals in the air had been a good one.
The more weight Exelixis gained, the more she sank toward the earth.
In fact, since among those hovering bodies,
hers was the largest mollusks and seaweeds and plankton began to gravitate about
her. And soon the child was covered with salicious little shells.
Chitnis carapaces and fibers of sea plants.
And the farther she vanished into that tangle,
the more she was freed of the Moon's influence until she grazed the surface of
the water and sank into the sea.
We rode quickly to pull her out and save her.
Her body had remained magnetised and we had to work hard to scrape off all the
things in crusted on her tender corals where roundabout her head.
And every time we ran the comb through her hair,
there was a shower of crayfish and sardines.
Her eyes were sealed shut by limpets cleaning to the lids with their suckers.
Squid's tentacles were coiled around her arms and her neck and her little dress
now seemed woven only of weeds and sponges.
We got the worst of it offer,
but for weeks afterwards she went on pulling out fins and shells and their skin
dotted with little diatoms remained effected forever.
Looking to someone who didn't observe her carefully as if it were faintly dusted
with freckles.
This should give you an idea of how the influences of earth and moon practically
equal fought over the space between them.
I'll tell you something else.
A body that descended to the earth from a satellite was still charged for awhile
with lunar force and rejected the attraction of our world,
even eye big and heavy as I was. Every time I had been up there,
I took a while to get used to the earth's ups and its downs and the others would
have to grab my arms and hold me clinging and a bunch in the swing boat while I
still had my head hanging in my legs, stretching up towards the sky,
hold onto us, hold onto us.
They shouted at me and in all that groping sometimes I ended up by seizing one
of Mrs v Hidden visits breasts,
which were round and firm and the contact was good and secure
and had an attraction as strong as the moons or even stronger,
especially if I managed as I plunged down to put my other arm around her hips
and with this I passed back into our world and fell with a thud into the bottom
of the boat where Captain Vaudeville had brought me around throwing a bucket of
water in my face.
This is how the story of my love for the captain's wife began and my suffering
because it didn't take me long to realize whom the lady kept looking at
insistently. When my cousin's hands clasped the satellite,
I watched Mrs Vid, Vid,
and in her eyes I could read the thoughts that the deaf man's familiarity with
the moon were arousing in her and when he disappeared and his mysterious lunar
explorations, I saw her become restless as if on pins and needles,
and it was all clear to me how Mrs [inaudible] had become jealous of the moon
and I was jealous of my cousin. Her eyes were made of diamonds.
Mrs [inaudible],
they flared when she looked at the moon almost challengingly as if she were
saying you Shan't have him.
And I felt like an outsider.
The one who leased under served all of this was my deaf cousin.
When we helped him down pulling him, as I explained to you by his legs,
Mrs [inaudible] had lost all her self control,
doing everything she could to take his weight against her own body,
folding her long silvery arms around him. I felt a pang in my heart.
The Times I clung to her, her body was soft and kind,
but not thrust forward the way it was with my cousin while he was in different
still lost and whose lunar bliss.
I looked at the captain wondering if he also noticed his wife's behavior,
but there was never a trace of any expression on that face of his eaten by Bryan
marked with tare wrinkles.
Since the death one was always the last to break away from the moon,
his return was the signal for the boats to move off.
Ben With an unusually polite gesture.
They had picked up the harp from the bottom of the boat and handed it to his
wife. She was obliged to take it and play a few notes.
Nothing could separate her more from the death one than the sound of the harp I
took to singing in a low voice.
That sad song that goes every shiny fish is floating,
floating, and every dark fishes at the bottom,
at the bottom of the sea and all the others,
except my cousin echoed my words
every month. Once the satellite had moved on,
the deaf one returned to his solitary detachments from the things of the world.
Only the approach of the full moon aroused him again.
That time I had arranged things so it wasn't my turn to go up.
I could stay in the boat with the captain's wife,
but then as soon as my cousin had climbed the ladder, Mrs [inaudible] said,
this time I want to go up there to this had never happened before.
The captain's wife had never gone up on the moon,
but for hid vid made no objection. In fact,
he almost pushed her up the ladder,
bodily exclaiming go ahead then and we all started helping her and I held her
from behind
and filter round and soft on my arms and had to hold her up.
I began to press my face in the palms of my hands against her and when I felt
her rising into the moon's sphere, I was heartsick at that last contact.
So I started to rush after her saying,
I'm going to go up for a while too to help out.
As I was held back as if in a vise you stay here, you have work to do later.
The captain commanded without raising his voice. At that moment,
each one's intentions were already clear and yet I couldn't figure things out.
Even now, I'm not sure I've interpreted it all correctly.
Certainly the captain's wife had for a long time been cherishing the desire to
go off privately with my cousin up there or at least to prevent him from going
off alone with the moon,
but probably she had a still more ambitious plan,
one that would have to be carried out in agreement with the death one.
She wanted the two of them to hide up there together and stay on the moon for a
month, but perhaps my cousin deaf as he was,
hadn't understood anything of what she had tried to explain to him or perhaps he
hadn't even realized that he was the object of the lady's desires and the
captain. He wanted nothing better than to be rid of his wife.
In fact, as soon as she was confined up there,
we saw him give free reign to his inclinations and plunge into vice and then we
understood why he had done nothing to hold her back.
But how do you know from the beginning that the moon's orbit was widening?
None of us could have suspected the death one perhaps,
but only he and the shadowy way he knew things.
He may have had a pre sentiment that would be forced that he would be forced to
bid the moon farewell that night.
This is why he hidden his secret places and reappeared only when it was time to
come back down on board.
There's no use for the captain's wife to try to follow him.
We saw her across the scale, each zone, various times, length and breadth.
Then suddenly she stopped looking at us in the boat as if about to ask us
whether we had seen him. Surely there was something strange about that night.
The sea's surface instead of being taught as it was during the full moon or even
arched of it toward the sky now seemed limp sagging as if the lunar magnet no
longer exercised its full power and the light too,
wasn't the same as the light of other full moons.
The Nice shadows seemed somehow to thickened our friends up there must have
realized what was happening. In fact,
they looked up at us with frightened eyes and from their mouths and ours at the
same moment came a cry. The moon's going away.
The cry hadn't died out. When my cousin appeared on the moon running,
he didn't seem frightened or even amazed. He placed his hands on the terrain,
flinging himself into his usual summer sold,
but this time after he hurt himself into the air,
he remained suspended as little excellent Dick's head.
He hovered a moment between moon and earth upside down.
Then laboriously moving his arms like someone swimming against a current.
He headed with unusual slowness toward our planet
from the moon. The other sailors hastened to follow his example.
Nobody gave a thought to getting the moon milk that had been collected into the
boats, nor did the captain scold them for this.
They had already waited too long. The distance was difficult to cross by. Now,
when they tried to imitate my cousin's leap or his swimming,
they remained there groping, suspended in midair, cling together.
Idiots clean together. The captain yelled at this command.
The sailors tried to form a group,
a mass to push all together until they reached the zone of the earth attraction.
All of a sudden,
a cascade of bodies plunged into the sea with allowed splash.
The boats were now rowing to pick them up. Wait, the captain's wife is missing.
I shouted. The captain's wife had also tried to jump,
but she was still floating only a few yards from the moon.
Slowly moving her long silvery arms in the air.
I climbed up the ladder and in a vain attempt to give her something to grasp.
I held the harp out toward her. I can't reach her.
We have to go after her and I started to jump up brandishing the harp above me.
The enormous lunar disc no longer seen the same as before.
It had become much smaller.
It kept contracting as if my gays were driving it away and the emptied sky gaped
like an abyss where at the bottom the stars had begun multiplying and the night
poured a river of emptiness over me drowned me in dizziness and alarm.
I'm afraid. I thought I'm too afraid to jump. I'm a coward.
And at that moment I jumped.
I swam furiously through the sky and held the harp out to her and instead of
coming toward me,
she rolled over and over showing me first her impassive face and then her
backside hold tight to me.
I shouted and I was already overtaking her, intertwining my limbs with hers.
If we cling together,
we can go down and there was concentrating all my strength on uniting myself
more closely with her and I concentrated my sensations as I enjoyed the fullness
of that embrace. I was so absorbed.
I didn't realize at first that I was indeed tearing her from her weight,
this condition, but was making her fall back on the moon.
Didn't I realize it or had that been my intention from the very beginning before
I could think properly, a cry was already bursting from my throat.
I'll be the one to stay with you for a month or rather on you.
I shouted in my excitement on you for a month
and at that moment our embrace was broken by our fall to the moon's surface
where we rolled away from each other among those cold scales.
I raised my eyes as I did every time I touched the moon's crust.
Sure that I would see above me, the native sea,
like an endless ceiling and I saw it. Yes, I saw it this time too,
but much higher,
much more narrow bound by its borders of coasts and cliffs and prominent Tories
and how small the boats seemed now and familiar my friends faces and how weak
their cries. A sound reached me from nearby Mrs Vid.
Vid had discovered her harp and was caressing it. Sketching out a chord is sad,
is weeping along month again.
The moon turns slowly around the earth on the suspended globe.
We no longer saw our familiar shore, but the passage of oceans is deep.
As a business in deserts of glowing Lapilon lie and continents of ice and
forests riding with reptiles and the rocky walls of mountain chains,
Gash by swift rivers and swampy cities and stone graveyards and empires of clay
in mud. The distance spread a uniform color over everything.
The alien perspectives made every image alien herds of elephants and swarms of
locusts ran over the planes so evenly vast and dense and thickly grown that
there was no difference among them.
I should have been happy because I had dreamed I was alone with her.
That intimacy with the moon I had so often envied my cousin and with Mrs v Hid
vid was now my exclusive prerogative.
A month of days and lunar nights stretched uninterrupted before us.
The crust of the satellite nourished us with its milk whose tart flavor was
familiar to us. We raised our eyes up to the world where we had been born.
Finally traversed in all its various expanse,
explored landscapes no earth being had ever seen or else we contemplated the
stars beyond the moon.
Biggest pieces of fruit made of light ripened on the curved branches of the sky
and everything exceeded my most luminous hopes and yet,
and yet it was instead exile.
I thought only of the earth.
It was the earth that caused each of us to be that someone he was rather than
someone else up there rested from the earth.
It was as if I were no longer that I know she, that she for me,
I was eager to return to the earth and I trembled at the fear of having lost it.
The fulfillment of my dream of love had lasted only that instant when we had
been United, spinning between Earth and moon torn from its earthly soil.
My love now knew only the heart-rending nostalgia for what it aware of
surrounding a before and after.
This is what I was feeling, but she, as I asked myself,
I was torn by my fears because if she also thought only of the earth,
this could be a good sign, a sign that she had finally come to understand me.
But it could also mean that everything had been useless,
that her longings were directed still. And only toward my deaf cousin.
Instead, she felt nothing.
She never raised her eyes to the old planet.
She went off pail among those wastelands, mumbling,
dirge and stroking her heart as if completely identified with her temporary.
As I thought lunar state
did this mean I had one out over my rival? No,
I had lost a hopeless defeat because she had finally realized that my cousin
loved only the moon and the only thing she wanted now was to become the moon,
to be assimilated into the object of that extra human love.
When the moon had completed its circling of the planet,
there we were again over the zinc cliffs.
I recognize them with this may not even in my darkest provisions that I thought
the distance would have made them so tiny in that mud puddle of the sea.
My friends had set forth again without the now useless ladders,
but from the boats, Rosa kind of forest of long poles.
Everybody was brandishing one with a harpoon or a grappling hook at the end,
perhaps in the hope of scraping off the last bit of moon milk or of lending,
some kind of help to us retches up there,
but it was soon clear that no pole was long enough to reach the moon and they
dropped back ridiculously short,
humbled floating on the sea and in that confusion,
some of the boats were thrown off balance and overturned,
but just then from another vessel, a longer pole,
which until then had been dragged along on the water's surface began to rise.
It must've been made of bamboo of many,
many bamboo poles stuck one into the other. And to raise it,
they had to go slowly because thin as it was, if they let it sway too much,
it might break.
Therefore they had to use it with great strength and skill so that the wholly
vertical weight wouldn't rock the boat.
Suddenly it was clear that the tip of that pole would touch
the moon and we saw it graze. Then press against the scaly terrain,
rest there a minute,
give a kind of little push or rather a strong push that made it bounce off
again.
Then come back and strike that same spot as if on the rebound then move away
once more.
And I recognized we both the captain's wife and I recognize my cousin.
It couldn't have been anyone else. It was playing his last game with the moon,
one of his tricks with the moon on the tip of his pole as if he were juggling
with her and we realized that his virtuosity had no purpose aimed,
no practical result. Indeed you would've said he was driving the moon away,
that he was helping her departure,
that he wanted to show her to a more distant orbit.
And this too was just like him.
He was unable to conceive desires that went against the moon's nature,
the moon's course and destiny.
And if the moon now tended to go away from him and he would take delight in this
separation just as till now he had delighted in the Moon's newness.
What could Mrs v hit for hit do in the face of this?
There was only at this moment that she proved her passion for the deaf man
hadn't been a frivolous whim, but an irrevocable vow.
If what my cousin now loved was the distant moon and she too would remain
distant on the moon.
I sensed this seeing that she didn't take a step toward the bamboo pole,
but simply turned her heart toward the earth, high in the sky,
and pluck the strings. I say I saw her, but to tell the truth,
I only caught a glimpse of her out of the corner of my eye because the minute
the pole had touched the lunar crust,
I had sprung and grasp it and now fast as a snake,
I was climbing up the bamboo nuts,
pushing myself along with jerks of my arms and knees,
light in the rarefied space,
driven by our natural power that ordered me to return to the earth.
Oblivious of the motive that had brought me here or perhaps more aware of it
than ever and if it's unfortunate outcome and already my climb up the swing pole
had reached the point where I no longer had to make any effort but could just
allow myself to slide headfirst attracted by the earth until in my haste,
the pole broke into a thousand pieces and I fell into the sea.
Among the boats
I return was sweeped by home refound,
but my thoughts were filled only with grief of having lost her and my eyes gazed
at the moon forever beyond my reach.
As I sought her and I saw her,
she was there where I had left her lying on a beach directly over our heads and
she said nothing. She was the color of the moon.
She held the Harper at her side and moved one hand now and then in slow
Arpeggios I could distinguish the shape of her bosom,
her arms, her thighs, just as I remember them now,
just as now when the moon has become that flat remote circle,
I still look for her as soon as the first sliver appears in the sky and the more
it wax is, the more clearly I imagine I can see her or something of her,
but only her in a hundred a thousand different vistas.
She who makes the moon the moon and whenever she is full sets the dogs to all
night long
and me with them.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the average Schreiber reading the distance of the moon by Italo Calvino and you
can hear him reading it again if you like, uh, on the selected should show yes,
like a choice.org is there a web address? Ours, radiolab.org.
You can hear it there too. We want to thank Sarah Montague,
Catherine Minton and BD Wong for making that Super Fun evening possible.
And of course, Juliette Schreiber call me and for you for listening.
Yeah, I'm Jen. I boom. Ron, I, Robert Krulwich, we'll see you next time.